alors où étiez-vous où tout
se passe j'étais dans ma voiture et
je conduisais juste donc j'étais peut-être à une
centaine de mètres de l'explosion ce qui
s'est passé euh je conduisais pas trop
loin de la ligne d'arrivée et tout d'un
coup j'ai juste  entendre cette grosse explosion
et au début j'ai pensé que c'était comme un
coup de feu ou quelque chose dont j'étais exactement sûr,
mais ensuite j'ai regardé en arrière et j'ai pensé que
c'était comme un tas de fumée juste en
l'air et un groupe de gens ont juste
commencé à courir ils étaient en train de cicatriser  la
façon dont je pouvais comprendre au début, je
ne pensais pas que c'était un gros problème, mais ensuite
vous avez une idée de la panique et ainsi de suite, je
n'avais aucune idée que des gens se
blessaient et j'ai entendu dire que comme certaines
personnes ont perdu, comment vous sentez-vous  cette
Trinity je pense que c'est un peu triste tu
sais que j'étais juste à la ligne d'arrivée tu
sais que mon ami avait traversé peut-être cinq ou
dix minutes avant l'explosion donc je suis
content que j'étais sur le point de sortir de là
mais oui c'est c'est triste  Je n'ai aucune idée de
ce qu'est ce monde  Je pense que
Boston était un endroit sûr ouais vraiment je l'ai
fait je veux dire je regarde le 11 septembre et
tu sais ça vaut pas mal de chemin depuis New
York tu sais donc ici à Boston je viens de
recevoir une sorte de naïf comme ça je
pensais que je  était en sécurité, mais à moins que je ne sois
content d'avoir été ajouté là-bas quand je l'ai fait